- Mo Brooks was finally served
in one of the insurrection lawsuits,
in potentially the most
hilarious way possible.
As you may or may not know, to
serve someone with a lawsuit,
often you have to physically
hand that to them.
And often people use process servers.
And in this particular case,
we have video of when Mo Brooks' wife
was served with this particular lawsuit.
The process server was trying
to get ahold of Mo Brooks
or his wife.
She was returning home.
The process server followed
her into the garage,
attempted to serve her and
then got back in his car.
At that point, she appears
to be incredibly pissed.
She gets behind his car,
ostensibly to get his
license plate number,
possibly to prevent him from leaving,
and then throws a hissy fit.
But that was probably
enough to effectuate service
in this particular lawsuit.
And yeah, sometimes
that's what you had to do
to serve someone with a lawsuit,
so you can see them in court.